[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهده في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى هذه
الصور من واشنطن ايجاز على واقع كثير من
التطورات حيث يتصدر حديث المساعدات
لاوكرانيا
واجهه الاحداث
حديث المساعدات العسكريه حاضر في المانيا
ايضا بعد الموافقه على تقديم الدبابات
لبرد ولكن في اتجاه اخر هذه المظاهره في
اليونخ للمطالبات بالحيادي في الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا ووقف تسليح كاف
بالعوده الى واشنطن ولكن في تطور اقتصاديا
هام حيث نشاهد مؤتمرا صحفيا بمجلس
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي بعد اماني رفع اسعار
الفائده خمسا 25 نقطه
وفي عالم الرياضه انطلاقه كاس العالم
للانديه في المغرب وهذه الصور من طنجه
التي تشهد في هذه اللحظات اولى مباريات
البطوله بين الاهلي المصري واوكلا سيتي ان
يوزلندي والاهلي متقدم بهدف دون شيء
في موضوع الحصاد
على موقع مزيد من الطلبات الاوكرانيه حديث
عن تجهيز واشنطن حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
تتضمن صواريخ ذكيه بعيده المدى
لاي محاوله اوكرانيه للاستهداف الاراضي
الروسيه
وفي الطريق الى بخموت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تقول انها سيطرت على مزيد من
المناطق
في تونس بعد دعوته الجيش والقضاء للتصدي
لمن سماهم المتامرين على الدوله جبهه
الخلاص ستتهم الرئيس سعيد بالخلط بين
مهامه الدستوريه والانتقام من معارضيه وفي
نظري تصعيد بين الصعيد واكبر نقابات
البلاد اتحاد الشغل يحذر من استهداف العمل
النقابي ويدعو الى التعبئه للدفاع عن
الحريه العامه
بريطانيا وشبحوا الازمه الاقتصاديه
المتصاعد
مع بدء اضراب هو الاكبر منذ عقد من الزمن
نصف مليون عاملا يشاركون في احتجاجاتنا
المطالبه برفع الاجور والحكومه تتمسك
بموقفها الرافد وتقول لنا اي رفع للاجور
سوف يفاقم التضخم في البلاد
في مباحثات تناقش تكثيف العمليات العسكريه
ضد حركه الشباب قمه رباعيه في مقديش
بمشاركه قاده جيبوتي وكينيا واثيوبيا
والصومال والحركه تستهدف محيطه قصر
الرئاسه بقذائف الهاون
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا التلويح الرئيس التونسي
باستخدام الجيش والقضاء ربما سماهم
المتامرين
مع المعارضه في البلاد جبهه الخلاص الوطني
ردت على حديث الرئيس متهمه اياه بالخلط
بين مهامه كرئيس وعداوته الشخصيه
اما اتحاد الشغل النقابه الاكبر في البلاد
فردا بالدعوه للتعبئه دفاعا عن الحريه
والحق في الاضراب محملا السلطات مسؤوليه
تبعات اعتقال احد نقابه استطلاع رايكم
بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي ماذا يضيف التوتر بين الرئيس سعيد
والاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل الى الازمه
المتفاقمه في تونس 40% توقعوا مواجهه بين
الرئيس والاتحاد بينما ذهب عشره في المئه
باتجاه خيار اعتماد الحوار اما 50% من
الاصوات فرجحت مدير الرئيس سعيد في قراره
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده متفاعله عربيا ودوريه
تتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
165 الف قطعه سلاح بيد المستوطنين عنوان
لمزيد من التصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
حديث المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا لا
يتوقف مع زياده الطلب الاوكراني تنقل
وكاله رويترز عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان
الولايات المتحده تستعد لتقديم حزمه
مساعدات الامنيه بقيمه مليارين ومئتين
مليون دولار تتضمن صواريخ بعيده المدى
للمره الاولى
يتجدد الحديث عن امكانيه تزويد اوكرانيا
بصوارخ طويله المدى الولايات المتحده تدرس
هذه الاحتماليه يقول مسؤولون امريكيون ضمن
حزمه مساعدات جديده بقيمه مليارين ومئتين
مليون دولار دون ان يحدد نوع ومتى
الصواريخ الممكن ارسالها حتى الان جل
واستلمته اوكرانيا من صواريخ لا يزيد
مداها على 100 كلم
وابرزها نسخه بيتريوت التي ارسلتها
الولايات المتحده ويصل مداها الاقصى الى
نحو 100 كيلو متر وهي صواريخ ارض جو
دفاعيه وليست هجوميه لكن عوائق كثيره تقف
امام توسيع استخداماتها اولها الحاجه الى
صاروخين على الاقل اعتراض هدف جوي واحد
ويصل ثمنه كل صاروخ الى نحو ثلاثه ملايين
دولار ايضا تستخدم اوكرانيا منظومه
الصواريخ هايبر اقصى ماذا يصل الى نحو 80
كم وتسلمت
ايضا منظومات ام ال ار اس 270 البريطانيه
التي يصل مداها الى نحو 80 كيلومترا
التحفظ الغالب على تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
بعيده المدى يكمن في القدره على استخدامها
في ضرب العمق الروسي هذا فضلا عن مدى وفره
كميات السلاح لدى الدول الغربيه المانحه
بشكل لا يؤثر على قدراتها العسكريه فرنسا
سبق ان حذرت من سيناريو مشابه وعشان تمسكت
برفض ارسال اي سلاح بعيد المدى او
استراتيجي كمقاتلات اف 16 خشيه تاجيج
الصراعي في اوكرانيا وما لم تحدده واشنطن
حول مدى الصواريخ حذر منه الكريم بل وضع
ما قد يكون اقصى مدى يسمح به واعتبر
الكرملين ان تزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ يصل
مداها الى 150 كيلومترا سيؤجيج الصراع اما
اوكرانيا فتصر على طلبها رفع مستويات
السلاح الذي تتلقى من دفعه الى هجومي
وتاخذ في ذلك جولات من المحادثات مع
شركائها الغربي
[موسيقى]
وقال انها لن تغير شيئا في سير هذه
العمليه لكنه اضاف ان امداد اكياس بهذه
النوعيه من الصواريخ سيصعد من مستوى
السرعه
ولكن في اخر تصريحاته قال الرئيس الروسي
الذيمر بوتين للمهمه الاساسيه امام موسكو
هي وقفه وندعو اي محاولات قصف من اوكرانيا
للاراضي الروسيه المستخدمه لها بحسب
تعبيره وهي اشاره ضنيه لاشكاليه مدى
الاسلحه ولقدرتها على الوصول الى نقاط بعد
نا هي القضاء على اي احتمال يتقصف غير ان
هذه المساله تعود الى المؤسسه العسكريه
العديد من السكان وجدوا انفسهم في ظروف
صعبه منهم فقد منزله او واجهه مشاكل في
الحصول على المياه والتدفئه مجلس الوزراء
توصل الى حلول من شانها دعم المناطق
المتاخم لاوكرانيا سنقوم بكل ما يلزم كي
لا يبقى السكان لوحدهم في مواجهه هذه
المشاكل
ونقش الموضوع مع ضيفنا من واشنطن كارت فول
كير السفير الامريكي السابق
عضو مجلس الدومه الروسي مرحبا بكما السفير
فولكر هل ستسمح الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اذا فعلا زودت اوكرانيا بصواريخ
بعيده المدى هل ستسمح بان تستهدف هذه
الصواريخ داخل روسيا الاراضي الروسيه
وبدينال استيكس هذا
الولايات المتحده الى اوكرانيا انا لا
نريد ان تستخدم الاسلحه الامريكيه
للاعتداء على الاراضي الروسيه لكن هناك
قوات روسيه
تحتل اجزاء من اوكرانيا ولا يمكن للقوات
الاوكرانيه ان تصل اليها
هذا المدى 80 كيلو مترا لا يمكن الوصول
اليها هناك انظمه يمكن ان تتخطى مسافات
ابعد تصل الى 150 كيلو مترا وهناك انظمه
اخرى تمتلكها الولايات المتحده تتخطى 300
كيلو متر ولكن الولايات المتحده لم تزود
اوكرانيا بها بعد
النوع من الصواريخ سيصعد من مستوى الصراع
ما الذي يمكن ان تفعله موسكو ايذاء هذه
الوكيله المتصاعده
بتسليح الغرب لاوكرانيا دبابات والان
الحديث عن صواريخ بعيده المدى
اولا اريد ان اقول ان روسيا تقوم بعملها
عسكريه قانونيه تماما ان اوكرانيا
واراضيها غير معترف بها قانونيا فهي منطقه
مختلف عليها من وجهه نظر القانون الدولي
لذلك توزيع الاسلحه هناك شيء ينقض
القوانين الدوليه واذا وصلت الاسلحه اذا
روسيا ستقوم بالضغط على الدول التي تقدم
هذه الاسلحه لاوكرانيا وقد تستخدم الاسلحه
النوويه
والان نحن ننظر الى هذا الدعم العسكري انه
لا يهدد روسيا الفيدراليه ولكن اذا بدات
هذه المعدات بتهديد روسيا اذا لدى روسيا
وسائل للدفاع عن نفسها وللتضغط على هذه
الدول التي تقوم باعمال غير قانونيه
السفير ما الذي اختلف
ميدانيا على الارض في اوكرانيا او حتى في
الاستراتيجيه التي تتبعها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
للوصول الى تزويد القوات الاوكرانيه بهذه
الصواريخ بعيده المدى
اوكرانيا هي اصلا غير مشروعه
السبب الوحيد الذي يقول
او بناء عليها السيد همم
ننزل 9 ليفانتي
مبرد هو امرنا غير مقبول حتى روسيا قالت
انها ااا ضمت هذه الاراضي ولا تسيطر عليها
كلها بعد انطلاق العمل اذا هذا امر غير
مشروع ماذا فعل الولايات المتحده الى
التفكير في ارسال صواريخ اضافيه اكثر مما
سبق هو انا روسيا تستمر في حشد القوات
والاعتداء على اوكرانيا
وكذلك تستخدم الاراضي المحتله لارتكاب
جرائم حرب فضيعه اوكرانيا بامس الحاجه الى
المزيد من الدعم لتحميل نفسها ضد اي
اعتداءات روسيه اضافيه ولكي تستعد اراضيها
طبعا الرئيس الروسي قال بان استهداف
الاراضي الروسيه خط احمر بنسبه له بطبيعه
الحال هل نفهم من هذا بان استهداف دنياك
وزبيلوجيا وخرسان بهذه الصواريخ بعيده
المدى قد يستدعي رد روسي ابعد من
الاسلحه التي تستخدمها روسيا الان
سؤالك سليم واريد ان اقول جديد من جديد
انا حسب القوانين الدوليه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هي مناطق مختلفه عليها ولا
يوجد اوكرانيا في الوثائق المتفق عليها
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه لذلك انظر في
عام 25 همم لم يكن
انفصال اوكرانيا عن الاراضي السوفيتي
قانونيه لذلك هذه مواقع انفصاليه لذلك لدى
روسيا حتى نوني ان تعيد النظام والسيطر
على هذه المواقع وهذا لا يعطي الحق لاي
دوله سواء كانت الولايات المتحده او غيرها
ان تقدم الاسلحه لاوكرانيا جميع الخطوط
الحمراء وهذا يضر بمصالح روسيا بطريقه
واضحه واذا حدث هذا بطريقه مستمره كما
يحدث روسيا هي الدوله الوحيده في العالم
التي ممكن ان تقف ضد امريكا بقدراتها
النوويه وروسيا سوف تنتصر في هكذا نذاع
ونحن الان نريد ان نغير النظام في العالم
نحن نريد ان نعيد النظام لمناطقنا
والولايات المتحده تقترب مزيدا الى حدودنا
وهكذا هي تهدد كل ما قامت ببنائه خلال
ثلاثين سنه وهذا غلط كبير من قبل الولايات
المتحده شكرا
عضو مجلس ادوما الروسي في موسكو
السفير الامريكي السابق لدى الناتو في
واشنطن
حاولي نفس الموضوع عند عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري واستراتيجي لواء
دويري ما التاثيرات المتوقعه لصواريخ
بعيده المدى في حال فعلا زودت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه القوات الاوكرانيه بها
يعني الان لو عدنا اشهر الى الوراء عندما
تم التزويد بمنظومتهمارس كانت الميداليات
ضمن مسافه 80 كيلو متر تعتبر اهداف
وادت الى نتائج ايجابيه بالنسبه للجانب
الاوكراني لان اتمكنت من تدمير معظم
مستودعات الذخيره ونقاط التكديس واصابه
ال- ال- القوافل وبالتالي حدث ارباك منذ
معركه خارف كيف اجيوم واخرسون وكان ذلك
بفعل همم هيمارس بصوره رئيسيه الان نتحدث
عن مدى 150 كم اي بمعنى اخر ان كافه
المنظومه اللوجستيه
والاداريه
وكافه التعزيزات ضمن هذا المدى ستكون
بمتناول هذه القذائف وبالتالي هذا سينكس
اذا ما تحقق
تم التزويد سيدنعكس على المعارك لاحظ في
الفتره الحاليه اليد العليا نسبيا هي
للجانب الروسي في معظم مناطق دونيست
وبالتالي هذه الذخائر اذا وصلت في الوقت
المناسب ستساعد في اعاده التوازن الميداني
ما بين طرفي الصراع ستبقى معنا لواء
الدولي سنتحدث عن الواقع الميداني في
الشرق الحديث عن المساعدات يتزامن مع
تطورات ميدانيه مستمره حيث ما زالت القوه
الروسيه تحول السيطره على ضخمت وسط تضارب
في الانباء بشان ذلك متابع التقرير التالي
ونعود الى النقاش مع اللواء
تقاوم ولكن
لا تخفي اوكرانيا صعوبه الموقف في بطنك
بالقرب من المدينه الاستراتيجيه الشرقيه
البلاد متضاربه
لحظه ضخمه باهميه استراتيجيه تقع على ضفه
نهر ضخم توفى شماليه مقاطعه دونياسك في
اقليم الدومباز وتبعد نحو 600 كيلو متر عن
العاصمه كيف
تعد المدينه بالنسبه للاوكرانيين للدفاع
عن باقي مدن
ومنطلقا لضربتها الى المواقع الروسيه اما
الروس فبعد خسارتهم مدينه ايزيوم جنوب
خارف اصبحت البوابه الجنوبيه الشرقيه
الوحيده لتقدم قوتهم فيضان
تبحث روسيا عن انتصار كبير على محور
مخبورت ما دفعها بحسب ما نقلته صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه الى تغيير
تكتيكاتها العسكريه اذ انتقلت من القصف
الصاروخي الى الدفع بموجات بشريه كبيره من
المقاتلين لاقتحام خطوط الدفاع الاوكرانيه
اما في خرسون جنوبا فتكثف القوات الروسيه
ضرباتها بتزامن مع نقل تعزيزات من شبه
جزيره القرم الى جنوب المقاطعه هل تتاهب
موسكو لامر ما يتجدد السؤال ومعه تنطلق
التكهنات حول هجوم في الربيع او ربما قبله
طالما نبهت كييف الى ان الروسي يعدون له
يقول امين مجلس الامن القومي الاوكراني ان
روسيا تستعد لشن هجوم كبير جديد على
اوكرانيا خلال اسبوعين او ثلاثه
ان هناك احتمالا كبيرا لشن بوتين هجوما
جديدا من الشمال والجنوب والشرق كما حدث
في بدايه الحرب كما يشير الى ان المعارك
الاصعب لم تاتي بعد وانا شهور قليله
المقبله ستكون حاسمه في تحديد مسار الحرب
الى ساحته
لاي محاوله اوكرانيه
يقول ان مهمه وزاره الدفاع هي منع ذلك
الاحتمال لكن بوتين لا يوضح ما اذا كان
النطاق الجغرافي الذي يقصده
من اراضي اوكرانيه اما انه يقف عند حدود
روسيا التي يعترف بها العالم
ما الذي يكسب بخموت هذه الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه للطرفين
يعني البوابه الجنوبيه واشارت تقرير بعد
سقوط ايزيوم اصبح الخيار الرئيسي للقوات
الروسيه
لاستعاده السيطره على دونسك تاتي عبر
سوليدار
سقطت سوليدار وكان هناك لا اقول اخطاء لكن
كان هناك قراءه
لم استطع ان يعني ان اقدر ما اتخذ لانه
كانت تعتبر سوليدار الخاسر الرخوه
وبعد السيطره على سوليدار تم السيطره ولو
تعبويا بالنيران على طرق المواصلات مما
سهل الحديث عن تطويق ولو بالنيران وليس
بالقوات لكن سقوطها
هي تسيطر الان على تعتبر عقده مواصلات
للطرق البريه
وللشكك الحديديه والسيطره عليها تقود
مباشره الى كرامترزق وسلافيا ديسك والى
ازييوم
وبالتالي اذا ما تحقق ذلك وقد يحتاج وقت
اذا ما تحقق ذلك نحن نتحدث في تلك اللحظه
عن امكانيه استعاده السيطره على اقليم
اليوسك بالكامل وهذا ما تتخوف منه القياده
الاوكرانيه عندما تتحدث عن هجوم رئيسي على
منطقه باخمود ومحيط باخم موت اللواء فايز
الدويري في عمان شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
لتونس بعد تلويح الرئيس قيس سعيد باستخدام
الجيش
السعيد وصل الى مازق كبير جعله يتخبط
ويخلط بين المهام بحسب وصف الجبهه
اتحاد الشغل توقيفه احد نقابه الى تعبئه
للدفاع عن الحريه والحق في الاضراب
مره اخرى يخاطب قيس سعيد التونسيين من
داخل احدى السكنات تزامنا مع تمديد حاله
الطوارئ في البلاد حتى نهايه العام يهدد
الرئيس كدابه ويتوعد من يصفهم في كل مره
بالخونه والمتامرين دون ان يسميهم مطالبا
بمحاسبتهم خطابه التهديد والوعيد فهم هذه
المره على انه موجه ضمنا للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل اكبر نقابه البلاد
يتولون اليوم التهديد بقطع الطريق السياره
لا يمكن ان يبقوا خارجه دائره المسائله
الحق النقابي مضمون
ولكن
الحق النقابي لا يمكن ان يتحول الى غطاء
لمقارب السياسيه لم تعد تخفى على احد
كلام وسعيد تلاهم مباشره اعتقال مسؤول
النقابي دعى الى الاضراب واغلاق طريق سريع
وسبقه تعيين نقبي معارض لقياده الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل كوزير للتربيه فيما
بدا اشاره لا تخطئها العين الى المنظمه
النقبيه
لاجتماع عاجل لمكتبه تنفيذي اعتبر عاقبه
في بيان انما حدث ياتي ضمن ما وصفها
بمحاولات تجهيش ضد الاتحاد لمنعه من لعب
ما وصفه بدوره تاريخي في انقاذ البلاد من
ازماتها السياسيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
لاسيما وانه يعد مبادره للانقاذ كما دعا
النقابيين للتعبئه والاستعداد للدفاع عن
الحق النقبي والحريه العامه والفرديه بكل
الاشكال الممكنه على حد وصفه
المعارضه من جهتها ترى في كلام سعيد نزعه
انتقاميه وسعيه لتصفيه خصومه عبر تخويمهم
كما تقول وتضيف وان خطاب سعيد الاخير يمثل
محاوله للتغطيه علامه سمتها الانتخابات
الفاشله بعد ما قطعها الشعب هو اليوم
يعني خطاب سواه خطاب تخويف ربما ترى له
انه عندما يذهب الى سكنه عسكريه او سكنه
بوليسيه المعارضه
تتخاف وايضا الشعب التونسي سيخف ولكن
اعتقد ان الخوف نسيناه منذ 2011
سياسيه في تونس دون ان تلوح في الافقي اي
بودره لحلها
يعيش المواطنون
صعب اجتماعته واقتصاديه
متلاحقه خاصه من ربح الجزيره تونس
نبقى في تونس ينضم الينا السيد محمد امين
الجربي عضو تحالف احرار السيد الامين
البوعزيزي الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي
مرحبا بكما سيد الامين لماذا ترون بزياره
رئيس الجمهوريه لثقنى عسكريه للحرس الوطني
وبتصريح من هناك بانه اقحام واستعانه
بالجيش واقحامه في صراعه السياسي
سعيد الى ساكنه ومخاطبه يعني التونسيين من
داخل السكن ياتي مباشره بعد اللطمه
الاخيره التي تلقاها في ماء سماها
بانتخابات في دورها الاول ودورها الثاني
انكشف همم يعني كذوب الحاضنه الشعبيه همم
المشهد السياسي تقريبا كله يقاوم الانقلاب
ويقول ان البلد تعيش انقلاب ماذا بقي له
التحرش بالمؤسسات الحامله الى السلاح
والتظاهر كونها تقف الى جانبه واصبح يعني
معناها يقوم بالتهديد المباشر همم يطالب
الاجهزه المسلحه بان يعني تحاكم الناس
خارج المحاكم بعد ما استعصى عليه ترويض كل
المؤسسه القضائيه اتحاد الشغل لهذه
المنظمه همم يعني همم لا تحتاج مني الى
تقديم لكن اقول قيادتها التي وقفت الى
جانب الانقلاب وزينت وهمم يعني وفرت له
الغطاء الاخلاقي والسياسي جاء عليها الدور
هذه الايام هو اليوم يهدد العمل النقابي
ويقول ان الاستثناء لا يستثنى احدا طيب
سيد محمد امين الجربي همم طبعا الرئيس قيس
سعيد طالب الجيش والحرس الوطني والقضاء
العسكري بمواجهه من يصفهم بالمتامرين حتى
الان صراحه لا احد يفهم بتونس من هم
المتامرون لماذا لا يسميهم الرئيس قيس
سعيد ااه بشكل مباشر ويتخذ اجراءات بحقهم
ايضا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله والسلام على ضيفه
الكريم
اولا قبل الاجابه على سؤالك العوينه ليست
تقنع عسكريه هي تقنه للحرس الوطني والحرس
الوطني يتبع وزاره الداخليه ثانيا الرئيس
تحدث عن اعتصامات تمولت من قبل نائب وهذا
اثبته القضاء
نائب عن حركه نداء تونس كان يمول
الاعتقامات لشركته الخاصه لقطع الطريق على
الدوله لنقل الفوسفات في قفصه وهذا اثبته
القضاء وهو تحدث علي رئيس الجمهوريه
والنائب
الجمهوريه ممكن ان يرد عليك يقول لك قائل
كانت تجمع هذا الشخص علاقه برئيس
الجمهوريه هذا ليس حديثنا اخبرني عن
المتامرين الان الان رئيس يقول كل من يقطع
الطريق من يتظاهر هو متامر على الدوله من
هم المتامرون
الرئيس يتحدث عن كل من يتظاهر وانت
والحديث في ايه اللي جاي يوم 14 يوم حدثت
حركه النهضه وجبت خلاص والخميسي وكل
الترفص السياسي المعارض حسدوا لم يجدوا
الالف 1300 شخص في شارع حبيب بورقيبه ولم
يتعرض لهم احد ورغم خلافهم للمسيله في
الملتقى عليها بين وزاره الداخليه ولايه
تونس
والمتظاهرين انفسهم قام الامنوا بحمايتهم
وبحمايه قيادتهم ولم يتعرض لهم احد نحن
نعيش في اسرع سوره الديمقراطيه من يريد له
ان يعرف ان يعارض ولا هو في الاخ قال
سابقا على الاتحاد الاتحاد يقولوا لاني
منظومه 24
ولكنه يريد التصحيح بعض المطارات في
المبادره وقد شكل لجين خاصه في هذه النظر
ولكن الرئيس
الاتحاد
السيد محمد امين سيد البوعزيزي
هذا الاشتباك همم بين الرئيس قيس سعيد
والاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل الاكبر
نقابه في تونس الى اي ممكن ان يؤدي بهذه
الاسماء
اولا هي رساله الى القياده المتنفيذه داخل
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل ان التنكر
الى ان البلد يعيش انقلاب وان التضحيه
يعني دق البرلمان بدبابه والغاء المشهد
السياسي وكل المؤسسات الدستوريه ويعني دوس
دستور الثوره سياتي اليوم الذي يعني سمر
الى الاتحاد وقد جاء اليوم لكن من الجانب
الثاني ايضا ان اعتقال مؤسسه الاتحاد في
يد قيادته المتنفذه المتنكره الى الحريه
او الديمقراطيه في تونس اجراءات قيس سعيد
ستعيد للاتحاد الى دوره التاريخي قدر
الاتحاد ان يكون يعني الى جانب
الديمقراطيه والى جانب الحريه ما يفعله
قيس سعيد يصحح مسار الاتحاد وقريبا سيجد
الاتحاد يدافع عن يعني مساله الحريه
والديمقراطيه لانه بتنكره لها سيطاله
الامر باعتقال اعتقال احد قياداته اليوم
هو تجريم للعمل النقابي على اعتبار ما
يجري اليوم ليس قطع الطريق هو اضراب مؤشر
قانوني معلن عنه وبالتالي ان لا يجري
اليوم في حق الاتحاد هو تقريبا رساله الى
هذه القياده ان الامر ومغازله الانقلاب لن
يعني تغفل لهم وسياتي عليهم الدوره نامل
استفاقتهم اجراءات قيس سعيد الاخيره ستكون
الامر الذي على قاعدته يستفيد قياده
الاتحاد وتعيد الاتحاد الى دوره التاريخي
لمنحاز الى الديمقراطيه باعتبارها بوابه
سيد محمد امين الجربي ايضا سؤال يطرح في
الشارع التونسي لماذا يشتبك الرئيس قيس
السعيد مع الجميع بعد القضاء والاحزاب
السياسيه
ويشتبك مع الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
الذي كما قلت انت في البدايه كان يؤيد
الاجراءات التي اتخذها الرئيس سعيد ولكن
الان يشت معه حتى يدعو للتظاهر حمايه
للحريات لماذا يشتبك الرئيس مع كل هذه
الاطراف في تونس
الرئيس حدد مسطارا من اوله ولا تراجع عنه
بدا بالاستشاره الالكترونيه وبدا باستفتاء
عليه
3 ملايين شخص والاخ يريد ان يلغيهم والذي
الغى دستور 2014
وينتهي بتركيز البرلمان ثم بالهيئات
الدستوريه
والاقاليم الرئيس معظم في مساره الاتحاد
كقوه تاريخيه ويريد الدفاع عن منظوره لدي
الحق الاتحاد امضى على الاتفاقيه
الاجتماعيه التي تنص على 5 زياده للموظفين
العموميين على ثلاثه سنوات وفي القطاع
الخاصي ايضا الاتحاد يريد التدخل في الشان
السياسي وهذا يراهم المشروعيته التاريخيه
ولكن الرئيس قيس سعيد يرى ان للاتحاد فقط
الدفاع عن منظوري والاتحاد
جراء اتباع واحد من قيادته لقضايا فتاه
سيبراها القضاء ام سيدينه هذا شان القضاء
السيد محمد امين الجربي اريد ان اسمع رايك
لو سمحت ابقى معك الان يظهر في العاجل على
شاشتنا الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول بان نسبه
المشاركه في الانتخابات التونسيه مؤشر على
ضروره تعاطي الحكومه مع الجميع بشمول اكثر
هذا بحسب الخارجيه الامريكيه ما تعليقك
السيد محمد امين الجربي
الان القائم بالاعمال امريكا هي امراه ولم
يعاني المستفيد الى حد الان امريكا
من اول التاريخ ان التونسيين اولى
بمشاكلهم تقريبا احتدم الوضع ووصل الطير
الى الذباب ووصلت الدماء
تدخل الاتحاد وتدخلت بعض القوى الاجتماعيه
لحفظ الديمقراطيه في تونس الشان التونسي
هو شان التونسيين ولا دخل للاجنبي بذلك
شكرا لكم شكرا
عضو تحالف احرار وسيد الامين البوعزيزي
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي
تصريحات الرئيس قيس سعيد الاخيره توسع
دائره خصومه داخل البلاد
فاستهداف القطاعات النقابيه لم يكن الى
الحلقه الاحدث في سلسله اجراءات وممارسات
بدات منذ الخامس والعشرين من يوليو قبل
عام ونصف العام
[موسيقى]
بخلاف علاقته مع القوى الامنيه يتزايد
المختلفون مع الرئيس التونسي منذ قراراته
مساء الخامس والعشرين من يوليو 2021 التي
اعتبرها خصومه انقلابا على الدستور
ومؤسسات الدوله تباعا بدا الاشتباك بين
مؤسسه الرئاسه ومؤسسات وكيانات منها من
كان ابدى قدرا من التفهم والهدوء اذا
قرارات الرئيس المتلاحقه لعام كامل مدد
الرئيس حاله الطوارئ ومن ثكنه تابعه للحرس
الوطني دعا الشرطه والجيش ومن سماهم
القضاه الشرفاء للتصدي للمتامرين على
الدوله وفق تعبيره مضيفا انتقادات للعمل
النقابي كان لها ما بعدها قبل تلك
التصريحات بيوم فقط خرج قيس سعيد معلقا
للمره الاولى على التراجع الحاد في نسب
المشاركه في الانتخابات التشريعيه لكنه
فاجا متابعيه بالدعوه لقراءه تلك النسب
بشكل مختلف متهما البرلمان السابق بالعبث
بالدوله والتحول لمؤسسه داخل الدوله وفق
تعبيره مشيرا لان الاكثريه لا تكترث
بالبرلماني ولا تثق فيه فهل تنذر هذه
التصريحات بغموض مصير البرلمان المقبل
خاصه بالنظر لنسب المشاركه المتدنيه التي
تمخض عنها
البرلمان كان اولى المؤسسات التي
استهدفتها قرارات الرئيس مساء 5 والعشرين
من يوليو قبل عام ونصف تجميدا ثم حلا
بالكامل ولم يكن المؤسسه الوحيده بل وقع
اشتباك مع القضاه ومجلسهم الاعلى افضى الى
حل المجلس بالكامل بل اقاله عشارات القضاه
في وقت لاحق في المقابلتهم سعيد بتوظيف
القضاء العسكريه للانتقام من خصومه وفق
تصريحات احمد نجيب الشاب رئيس جبهه الخلاص
المحامون في تونس ايضا تظاهروا مطلع العام
غضبا مما اعتبره تراجعا في الحقوق
والحريات ومن ثقل وطاه التضخم والازمه
الاقتصاديه يمارس الرئيس التونسي منفردا
منذ عام ونصف ويتولى وحده اقاله المسؤولين
التنفيذيين وتعيين غيرهم قبل يومين اجرى
تعديل وزاريا محدودا دون ابداء اسباب ولا
يكف عن تعليق كل ازمات البلاد في رقبه من
يتهمهم دوما بالخيانه والفساد دون ان
يسميهم واللافث ان الازمات تتفاقمه رغم
اقصائي كل خصوم الرئيس
[موسيقى]
اضرابات العماليه هي الاكبر منذ عشر سنوات
شارك فيها نصف مليون شخص ينتمون الى
نقابات معلمين مدارس وسائقي القطارات
والحفلات وحراس الامن والمحاضرين
الجامعيين وموظفي الخدمه المدنيه وذلك
للاحتجاج على تدني الاجور وللمطلبه برفع
رواتبهم في ظله موجه الغلاء وادت
الاضطرابات الى شلل كبير في قطاعات عديده
بينما بدات الحكومه ثابته على موقفها برفض
مطالب النقابات
[موسيقى]
غضب المتقاعد في الشارع البريطاني وتنسيق
بادن بين النقابات لتصعيد الضغوط على
الحكومه مئه الالاف اضربهم مدرسون واساتذه
جامعات وموظفون عموميون وحكوميون وثائقي
قطارات وغيرهم اغلب المدارس اغلقت اما
كليا او جزئيا وشبكه القطارات شلت بشكل
شبه تامه وكذلك اكثر من مئه مرفق حكوميه
ومسيره وتظاهره حاشده على باب الحكومه
اليوم لارسال رساله واضحه لهذه الحكومه
انه لا يمكنها الاستمرار في التجاهل هذه
المشكله وان محاولاتهم لحلها عبر
التشريعات جديده لن تجدي من الحكومه تقول
انها منحت المدرسين خمسه في المئه زياده
في رواتبهم لكنها لا تقول انها اخذت هذه
الاموال من مخصصات الاطفال في ميزانياتها
يطالب المضربون بزياده رواتبهم لتناسب
معدلات التضخم وتلك بلغت اعلى مراتبها في
اكثر من اربعين عاما لكن الحكومه ثابته
على موقفها
عندما يتعلق الامر بالمعلمين فقد اعطيناهم
اعلى زياده في الاجور منذ 30 عاما تعلموا
اطفالنا ثمين للغايه وهم يستحقون ان
يكونوا في المدرسه اليوم ليتعلموا يجب ان
تخرج المعارضه وتقول ان الاضرابات خطا وان
علينا ان ندعم اطفالنا في المدارس
تقول الحكومه انها التزمت بتوصيات هيئات
مراجعه الاجور المستقله في تقدير زيادات
الاجور لكن هذا اقل بكثير مما تطلبه
النقابات المعركه مستمره اذن ومجلس
النقابات المهنيه الذي يجمع تحت مظلته
عشرات النقابات بات مشاركا فيها
اكبر من نوعه في بريطانيا منذ اكثر من 10
سنوات لكن الاهم فيه ان الدخول مجلس
النقابات المهنيه على خط المواجهه المباشر
مع الحكومه ينقل تلك المواجهه الى مرحله
جديده مرحله قد تكون سمعتها الابرز
التصعيد اسد الله الصاوي الجزيره لندن
الاقتصاد بجامعه نوتنغهام ومدير الابحاث
في مؤسسه القرار للدراسات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
نتحدث عن نصف مليون متظاهر ومحتاج الى متى
تتوقع ان تستمر الحكومه ثابته على موقفها
في مواجهه هذه الاضرابات الشعبيه
اعتقد ان المساله سوف تستمر واشهر قبل ان
تفضل هذا الاحتجاجات انها سبب وراء
الاحتجاجات والاضرابات فهي تدهور القوه
الشرائيه فمن يعمل في القطاع العام لم يعد
بامكانه ان يشتري اماكن يشتري به من قبل
من خلال اجوره بسعيد التضخم التضخم رده
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا التي اثرت على كل
اوروبا لا تريد الحكومه ان تدعم
العاملين في القطاع العام لان هذا يعني
انها ستحرم قطاعات اخرى منها توقعت ان
تستمر لوقت طويل ما خيارات الحكومه اذا
فعلا استمرت هذه الاحتجاجات والاضرابات
وزاد زخمها ايضا
وان يحفظه على المدى القصير امامها بعض
الخيارات مثلا
او المسؤولون عن تحقق من الجوازات وضبط
الجوازات كانوا مضربين واستبدلوا بعناصر
من الجيش على المدى الطويل ما يهم ليس
المظاهرات والاضرابات بل ما اذا اراد
الناس ان يعملوا في القطاع العام في مجال
التعليم والصحه
والشرطه وهذا فعلا يعتمد على ما اذا كان
معدل البطاله مرتفعا ام لا وما اذا ارتفعت
الرواتب والاجور نرى ان الاجور ترتفع في
القطاع الخاص والبطاله
متدنيه
وذلك في القطاع الخاص اذا ليس على الحكومه
التعامل فقط مع الاضرابات
والمظاهرات بل ايضا مع شهور المناصب
وظائف هل سياء ارغب الناس ويستمرون في
رغبه في الانضمام الى القطاع العام من
اسباب الازمه التضخم وسبب التضخم الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا هل هل يمكن احتواء
النتائج السلبيه لهذه الحرب ليس فقط في
بريطانيا وانما في عموم اوروبا
[موسيقى]
ساعد الناس ولكن ليس فقط موضوع الطاقه بل
ايضا موضوع المواد الغذائيه على المستوى
العالم اذا كنت تستورد الكثير من الواد
الغذائيه وارتفعت اسعار الطاقه في الدول
الاوروبيه سوف تزداد
يتكبده
القطاع العام ولكن ايضا موظف القطاع الخاص
حيث تفرد عليهم
لا يسعى سوى ترفع الضرائب وبتالي على
الحكومه ان تتخذ خيارا بين مواجهتها
الاضرابات والشهور في الوظائف العامه او
زياده الاجور في القطاع الخاص ما يتطلب
رفع الضرائب وطبعا مشاركه كل المواطنين
اذا ازداد فقرا زاد الفقر في البلاد هذا
سين على اوروبا كلها ولم تكون الخيارات
كثيره شكرا لك السيد جريجوري في لندن
[موسيقى]
اختتمت في العاصمه الصوماليه مقديشو قمه
رباعيه بمشاركه رؤساء الصومال جيبوتي
وكينيا ورئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي وناقشت
القمه سبل تنسيق الجهود في محاربه حركه
الشباب في هذه الاثناء افاد مراسل الجزيره
بسماع يدوي في جارات بقذائف هاون في
العاصمه مقديشو واعلنت حركه الشباب
مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم
ثلاثه رؤساء من دول الحوض الصومالي في
مقديشو هاجس المشترك يؤرقهم ومعهم الصومال
تجديد حركه الشباب التي ضلت شوكه في خاصره
الحكومات الصوماليه المتعاقبه على اجدد
المباحثات تهديدات الحركه وسبل مواجهتها
ووضع اليه لتعليم خطيرها والاهم بالنسبه
الى دول الجوار هو ضمان عدم انتقال مخاطر
الحركه الى اراضيها
القمه بشكل عام هو الاشاده بالتقدم الذي
احرزه الصومال في محاربه الارهاب
وضروره احترام دول الجوار وحده الصومال
واستقلاله وسياده اراضيه كما اتفق
المشاركون في القمه على تقديم دعم كامل
مادي ومعنوي للصومال وجيشه
تشارك كل من جيبوتي واثيوبيا وكينيا باكثر
من ثمانيه الاف جندي ضمن بعثه الاتحاد
الافريقي العامله في الصومال ويرى مراقبون
ان التزام هذه الدول بانخراط اكبر في
العمليات الجاريه ضد حركه الشباب ياتي
لتحقيق اهدافه مشتركه
دول باعتاده العسكريه الكامل
هذه الدول وتتوا من انتقاله الحركه الى
اراضيها لذلك تسعى لمحاربه الحركه او
اضافه تاثيراتها الامنيه
القمه الرباعيه قد تكون مكسبه للحكومه
الصوماليه بالمعنى السياسي الا ان نجاحها
يظل رهنا بترجمه مقرراتها الى افعال
ملموسه في ميدان لمواجهه بين تلك الدول
مجتمعه وحركه الشباب
اكثر من جبهه تشتعل داخل الصومال بين
الحكومه وحركه الشباب ونجحت الحكومه في
استرداد مناطق واسعه في الاقاليم الوسطى
الصوماليه غير ان قله العتاد العسكريه
بسبب الحاضر السلاح المفروض على الصومال
يجعلها اضعف لمواجهه الحركه التي تعتمد
على حرب العصابات الامر الذي يجعل حاجه
الحكومه الى دعم دوليه اكثر الحاحا من اي
وقت مضى جامع نور الجزيره
[موسيقى]
نعود الى القضيه الفلسطينيه ومعاناه
الفلسطينيين حيث قال رئيس هيئه مقاومه
الجدار والاستيطان مؤيد شعبان ان السلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والمستوطنين نفذوا
اكثر من 700 اعتداء خلال شهر يناير
المنصرم بلغت الاعتداءات التي نفذها
المستوطنون 150 اعتداء مع محاوله الان
جديده في مناطق متفرقه واكد شعبان ان قوه
الاحتلال والمستوطنين قاموا بتجريف
541 دون من اراضي الفلسطينيين في سلفيت
ونابلس وتحويلها لصالح المستوطنين وبلغت
عمليات الهدم التي نفذتها القوات
الاسرائيليه احدى 81 عمليه خلال الشهر
الماضي تركزت في القدس واريحا والخليل
الحديث عن اعتداءات المستوطنين يتزامنوا
مع قرار للحكومه الاسرائيليه بمنح
المستوطنين مزيدا من الرخص لحمل السلاح
بحجه تعزيز اجراءات حمايتهم جرسوا انذار
يدقوا من جديد بشان احتمال ارتكاب مزيد من
الانتهاكات في حق الشعب الفلسطيني تفيد
تقديرات لجنه الامن في الكنيست نشرها موقع
شومرين ويعني المراقبين بالعربيه مطلع
يوليو الماضي فانه حتى عام 2000
كان هناك مئه وخمسون الف قطعه سلاح بيد
المستوطنين ويبلغ عدد المستوطنين في الضفه
الغربيه والقدس المحتله
700,000 ويتوقع زياده قطع السلاح خمسه عشر
الفا خلال العام الجاري لتصبح 100
و65.000 او ربما اكثر مع ترجيح زياده
الانتهاكات والاغتيالات ضد الفلسطينيين
العزل على يد المستوطنين وقوات جيش تلال
قتل المستوطنين وجيش الاحتلال بل قتل جيش
الاحتلال والمستطيل خلال عام 2022 وفق
مركز معلومات فلسطين 100 و76 فلسطينيا
بالضفه الغربيه
والقدس الخارجيه الفلسطينيه طلبه المجتمع
الدولي بادراج تنظيمات المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين على قوائم الارهاب فقد نفذت
تلك التنظيمات في ليله واحده خلال هذا
الاسبوع 120 اعتداءا شمالي الضفه الغربيه
وكانت العصابات والمليشيات المسلحه
للمستوطنين ارتكبت خلال العام الماضي ما
لا يقل عن
849 اعتداءا على الفلسطينيين وممتلكاتهم
في الضفه المحتله في
2008 منها وقعت اصابات وفي 200 و61 وقعت
اضرار في الممتلكات وفق معطيات لامم
المتحده واضافه الى عشرات التنظيمات
المتطرفه
ثقه في عام 2022 تشكيل مسلح جديد في بئر
السبع تحت اسم دوريات برئيل
وشكل مستوطنون سفوح الجبال مجموعات
اجراميه مثل شبيبه التلال ومن كثره
الميليشيات وسريه عمل بعضها لا يعرف عددها
الاجمالي واستحقيقه منح حكومه الاحتلال
مزيدا رخص الاسلحه
للمستوطنين لنفهم الصوره اكثر وتداعيه
تنضم الينا من حيث سيد جوني منصور
الاكاديمي والباحث في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
سيف جوني ما الذي يعنيه زياده تسليح
المستوطنين في هذه المرحله
طبعا هذا سيؤدي الى
سرعه الضغط على الزناد في كل حاله من
الحالات ضمن اطار الحياه المدنيه وهذا
بطبيعه الحال شكل من الميليشيات التي
ستنتشر في مناطق مختلفه سواء كان في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله او داخل اسرائيل وعلى وجه
الخصوص الحديث يدور الان عن المدن
المختلطه مثل حيفافه ضد الرمل وعكا والتي
جرت فيها في عام 2021 هبت الكرامه في ايار
والتي ادت الى اشتباكات همم سواء كانت
مسلحه او غير مسلحه بين قطعان من
المستوطنين المسلحين تحت حمايه الجيش
الاسرائيلي والشرطه وحارس الحدود بالهجوم
على سكان العالم في هذه المدن لنفهم
المخاطر المخاطر اكثر معروف بان جيش
الاحتلال وان كان بالحد الادنى
اليه قوانين وقواعد وقواعد اشتباك ولكن
ماذا بشان المستوطنين من يطلق النار من
المستوطنين على همم على فلسطين هل يخضع
لاي تحقيقات هل يخضع لاي اجراءات قانونيه
مثلا
يعني اذا كانت عمليه اطلاق النار ذات
خلفيه همم فيها شكوكوك بان الفلسطيني
سيقوم انا اقول سيقوم احتمال ان يقوم بعمل
تعتبره اسرائيل الارهابيا فهذا المستوطن
او غيره من حمله السلاح من المدنيين يطلق
النار تحت ذريعه الدفاع وحمايه الامن
العام للمواطنين الاسرائيليين وهذا بطبيعه
الحال سيؤدي الى حاله من الانفلات في داخل
المجتمع وخصوصا بان المجتمع الاسرائيلي
اليهود بوجه خاص هم المسلحون اكثر من
المجتمع المدني الفلسطيني في الداخل بوجه
خاص سريعا هل ممكن ان هذه الخطوه ان تزيد
من حده المواجهه بين الفلسطينيين
والمستوطنين اذا
وهذا امر طبيعي بانه تحويل مساله حمايه
المستوطنات والدفاع عن المستوطنين الذين
يتحركون ويتنقلون في الضفه الغربيه هذا
سيؤدي الى سرعه اطلاق النار على
الفلسطينيين لان
تشكيك في تحرك الفلسطيني وبالتالي هذا
سيؤجج الحاله الامنيه في المنطقه وسيؤدي
الى تصعيد اكثر واكثر خصوصا ان
الفلسطينيين لن يقفوا مكتوفين ايدي مقابل
مثل هذه التحركات الحاصله الان بتزويد
وتسليح المستوطنين وجحافلهم مقابل
الفلسطينيين شكرا لك سيد جوني منصور
الاكاديمي والباحث في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
حدثتنا من حيفا
[موسيقى]
انا طبعا زي ما انتم شايفين هون الاولاد
بيلعبوا هون بالحاره
هذه القوات الاحتلال جايين انهم يدخلوهم
بدهم يحبسونا بدور بدورنا طبعا نحنا الهوى
انا طبعا زي ما انتم شايفين هون الاولاد
هذا المقطع الذي تبعناه الان كان من منطقه
بطن الهوى في بلده سلوان في القدس عنوانه
ممنوع اللعب مشهد مر علينا في نحو ثلاث
وعشرين ثانيه لكنه جزء يومي من حياه
الاطفال الفلسطينيين في كثير من احياء
القدس والضفه حسابات جيش الاحتلال تطلق
صافره النهايه وتعلن موعد العوده الى
المنزل والبقاء فيه جزء من معاناه يوميه
فيها الكثير والكثير من الفصول نهايه
الحصاد شكرا للمتابعه الى اللقاء بامان
الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]